it's Friday so you know what that means
let's welcome tonight's guest you may
recognize him from his feature in
average white guy magazine co-host of
fox and French first Todd
pyro as former Miss Citrus she comes
freshly squeezed host of the Morgan oras
show and Series XM Morgan
oras it's been 12 years since she tested
positive for food New York times
bestselling author and functions
contributor
ctip and the Great Barrier Reef is his
loofah New York Times bestselling author
comedian NAA world champion
Tyrus all right before we get to some
news stories let's do
this Gregs leftovers what's they heard
yeah it's leftovers where I read the
jokes we didn't use this week and as
always it's my first time reading them
so if they suck we'll put Joe Macky in a
meat grinder and turn him into hot
dogs so here we go oh fingers crossed
during a house committee speech Democrat
congresswoman prila gapul accused former
president Donald Trump on Wednesday of
inciting an
erection something she's never been
given of
herself
terrible Chris Christie announced he's
dropping out of the GOP Presidential
race quote it was difficult to support
his platform said
the said the workers who designed the
debate
stage W and like many politicians who
drop out Christy says he's looking
forward to taking some time off and
spending more time with his
family Jesus according to a report kamla
Harris has created her own scented
candle and just like her it gets lit
every
night she's a
drunk Top Gun three is in the works at
Paramount Pictures in this next
installment Maverick will take on his
biggest pH yet an enlarged
prostate we all will all get there the
girls high school basketball game was
cancelled after players hurled
anti-semitic slurs against their Jewish
opponents I know shocking right Jewish
basketball
players and Oklahoma 13-year-old is
believed to be the first person to ever
beat the video game Tetris incredible
when I was his age I was beating
something
else this is where we're going oh no I
don't know what that
means the FAA issued a safety update
after Alaska Airlines midair blowout uh
warning that parents not to hold
unsecured babies on their laps they
Airlines clarified that there will be an
upgrade fee if you're in coach and your
baby ends up in first
class in a related story an aviation
firm claims it's developed a jet fuel
made entirely from human
poop which means I finally sold some
sucker all my boxes of
poop uh the city council in St Paul
Minnesota will now be made up entirely
of women first order of business new
drapes no one's safe No One Is
Safe a company in the UK has created
bananas that never turned brown great
now bananas are
racist this week a rocket was launched
into space with the intention of
releasing the remains of 330 people
including George Washington
JFK and Joe
[Laughter]
Biden rep reports claim oh
no I know hey I'm not proud of
this
reports claimed that Jeffrey Epstein
tried to stop a rumor that he once
invited Stephen Hawking to the island
for a conference which led to his
alleged underage orgy e which seems like
a ridiculous rumor since kids rarely eat
their
vegetables that is the
worst worst
joke I've ever
heard I am firing Ducey for sending that
to it is true
though kids hate vegetables what the
hell I know reports claim that over
2,000 migrants have displaced students
at a Brooklyn High School the downside
is the students missed in-person classes
the upside the Landscaping was
amazing is so racist terrible racist
joke it's why it's not on the
show on an episode of The View whoopy
Goldberg said she believes if Trump wins
in 2024 he'll get rid of journalists and
gay people well there goes
[Laughter]
Bravo not the housewives according to
researchers holding in a fart in public
can lead to horrific
consequences see that's why I'm so
healthy said one man
[Applause]
wow a remake of The Blob is in the works
and Hollywood is already Scouting For
the main
star finally a relationship expert
address the real reasons why your
partner won't have sex with you it may
be caused by a lack of confidence wealth
or if you look like this I knew that
was I sat up straight I got ready I knew
it was coming yeah I'm butting that
shirt now to the news ESPN's in a jam
because they ran an Emmy stealing scam
and now they're in the Hall of Fame when
it comes to using bogus names this is
the weirdest story according to a report
from the athletic ESPN has admitted to
operating a scam going back Decades of
using fake names of people who didn't
exist to obtain more than 30 emys for
their onair
talent I know here's my question why
didn't Fox think of
that this is so here's how it went down
according to rules set by the academy on
a talent could win individual Emmys but
not as part of the staff of a show so to
skirt this rule ESPN would insert fake
names on Emy submissions under the guise
of associate producers now for for those
of you unaware of what an associate
producer does my
laundry but if they won and they did
they re-engraved the awards and then
gave them to onair personalities who
actually didn't
win I know what's hilarious is that for
the fake names ESPN made up it's like
they were barely trying to hide it so
Lee Corso was Lee Clark Kirk herb Street
was Kirk Henry Desmond Howard was Dirk
Howard Samantha Ponder was Steve
Ponder wow not only did she get a fake
name they also reassigned her
gender someone get Riley gains on the
phone whereas ESPN calls her Riley
green the report notes that there was no
evidence the onair talent was aware of
this scam and ESPN has returned the
statues to the academy we go to the ESPN
Talent now who had their statues
[Applause]
returned but the big question is why the
hell they do this well a person involved
in the ESPN me submission process said
quote you have to remember that those
personalities are so important and they
have
egos which is a shame for it gives TV
personalities a bad name because not all
of us have egos I don't come here to do
this show every single day so I can win
some fancy statue plus it's not like I
needed Emmy I already have you know a
Nobel Peace
Prize and a Mr Universe
trophy
and Mrs
Universe I won that on my own and an NBA
Defensive Player of the
Year but seriously the accusation of
cheating couldn't come at a worst time
for ESPN as the network just finished a
tribute to the most honest athletes of
all time like Lance Armstrong and Barry
Bonds and the East German women's swim
team yeah we made fun of them back
then Todd this is pretty amazing um have
you ever won an Emmy I have not right um
do you ever wish you had I I actually
applied and in local news you actually
have to apply yourself and pay your own
fee in to win the eny so that leads me
to my conclusion there is no way in hell
that the onair talent did not know about
this scheme right if for no other reason
then people in this business talk and it
is a small business so if you see sports
caster X at another station win the
award you know you've done your research
you've been monitoring the Emmys you
know they won that award so when
randomly a package shows up in your mail
and says you won the award you know it's
not yours second point though Greg you
ran the names one thing you didn't
mention about those names those are all
adult film star
names Dirk Howard Kirk Henry Chris
Fulton Lee Clark and Steve
Ponder okay that is an amazing fact and
I love you for that but I also want to
know how
[Laughter]
[Applause]
you oh that's that makes this whole
story
worthwhile GL I can make it about me
unintentionally always seems to happen
on this show torical question how did
you know that cuz I got to be honest
everyone remembers the women's names
remembers the guys name how did you
know I need to
know Tyrus Greg and Cat Morgan I believe
in knowing being well-rounded and
knowing all aspects of the entertainment
industry I need to know the competition
in case one of these individuals you
know applies to be the anchor on Fox and
Friends first so when you when it comes
to research you'd say you're pretty anal
[Applause]
[Laughter]
all right we got to move on no no stay
here greatest I a lot my time for
explanation greatest segment ever
everybody's yielding their time to you
to beat up on me and the porn addiction
you just made up on national TV you kind
of put it out there BR yeah you know
Morgan uh in 2002 you won your Miss
Citrus title but did you
really did you
really why would they do this I okay I
think I have a theory I think it's
because we spent so much time as a
culture giving out participation
trophies and now it's like the next
Natural Evolution from participation
trophies you're just like rigging the
system to give it to everybody I don't
know I mean listen no one's ever going
to accuse me of being Sporty Spice but
like I thought you're not supposed to
cheat in Cas like you would think ESPN
would know that yeah well you know what
they every time they Veer away from
Sports they screw up they should just
stick to reporting what's on the field
cat so in short these emys were
improperly obtained it's like the media
equivalent of Stolen Valor as a member
of the media and married to a veteran
this must be doubly
offensive
exactly no this makes so little sense I
remember I talked to Tom the Grom I
actually was worried that I was stupid
even though we all know that's not true
because I couldn't understand it
couldn't understand it because it's you
know you win an Emmy it's like okay for
13 years this went on and not a single
one of these people was like wait but I
wasn't invited to the
ceremony if somebody just like handed me
an Emmy with my name on it congrats I'd
be I'd start laughing or or it just
shows up at your house and also we're
all on TV right if you win an award
what's the first thing you're going to
do yeah Google yourself exactly see what
other people are saying about it we are
all we're all insufferable at least I
can admit it um but not a single one of
these people Googled themselves and to
see that the list not a single one of
them was like wait I I I would have
liked to go to the ceremony and have
pictures of myself taken not a single
one of the people in literally the most
narcissistic profession that there is
which is being on air had that thought
or asked that question I am not buying
that for a second what do you think
Tyrus I'm buying it yeah no no because
what they did was it's the part that
doesn't go on TV it's the team and
they're part of the team so it's like
the producers earned it for putting up
with their arrogant asses but to spit in
the face of producers well we got to
make sure that little grey here gets a
trophy too yeah so they're like oh
you're not up for the individual one
it's the team one but all emmies are you
have to pay yeah if you have to pay so
if you have the greatest number one late
night show but the host is cheap you
don't get an Emmy you know what I'm
saying let's not forget this is the guy
who offered me 20 bucks to break up
protest cuz I was black so when that
Emmy Priceless came out he was like we
don't need it we're good on Integrity so
Tyrus don't worry I've got tickets for
all of us to the adult
video we'll all be going you know I have
a feeling you're like you know the guy
like the
directors and you're like your role it
was like you were probably in them at a
younger time in your life but you were
in the non-action part you were like the
one pie of deler dely guy in the porno
who they take the pizza from and close
the door they did need the whitest guy I
was in the list it makes sense though
because what other group of people
besides you is getting off work at 6:00
in the
morning yeah all right we got to move on
up next we're talking to the vake cuz
the country's at
stake great hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most comp comping
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else